bigquery is a fully managed petabyte
scale low-cost analysis warehouse
you can access and share analytics and
sites in your organization with a few
clicks
while bigquery has robust security and
governance controls to keep your data
safe within your organization
it's important to keep sensitive data
inaccessible to unauthorized third
parties and reduce data exfiltration
risks
event threat detection is a built-in
service for the security command center
premium
tier that continuously monitors your
organization
and identifies threats within your
system in near real time
it includes a finding type for bigquery
data exfiltration
which can help alert you when an
unauthorized actor attempts to extract
or expose sensitive data in bigquery
whether on purpose or by accident
bigquery data exfiltration works by
examining audit logs for two scenarios
a resource is saved outside your
organization or a copy operation is
attempted that's blocked by vpc service
controls
or an attempt is made to access bigquery
resources that are protected by vpc
service controls
in order to use bigquery data
exfiltration first enable event threat
detection with an scc premium
subscription if you want to set up etd
check out our episode on how to use
event threat detection
let's imagine a malicious actor was
tasked with stealing the financial data
set
from the organization gcp sec demo
org they attempt to push results to an
external table located in a different
google cloud organization
project and bigquery destination table
if the gcp sec demo organization did not
have etd enabled
the malicious actor can quickly perform
the query and extract data
to another project under a new table if
they have the right permissions
while the action is logged it happens
mostly under the radar
by the time someone notices the job will
be complete and the data has likely been
exfiltrated
luckily this organization has enabled
etd
and when the malicious actor attempts
etd will surface the finding immediately
including when it was discovered the
category
under source properties the project
found in and data associated with the
exfiltration attempt
including the detection category and
rules exfiltration to an external table
and job state succeeded below you can
find the destination bigquery dataset
and table ids
and the person who submitted the job the
finding directly links to the job
so that if the job had not yet succeeded
you can now follow the link and stop the
job before completion
you can also add a vpc service perimeter
by heading to the vpc service control
console
service parameters are an organization
level method to protect google cloud
services in your projects
in order to mitigate the risk of data
exfiltration
give it a name leave parameter type as
default
and select enforced mode to prevent
access to protected services
select the project restricted services
bakery api vpc accessible services
access level and click save the idea is
that the legitimate users of the data
set are aware of the perimeter violation
if some malicious actor got access to
the data set but was not aware of the
perimeter
attempting to exfiltrate or even
legitimately use bigquery at all
would result in the violation finding
being generated
now if the malicious actor attempts to
exfiltrate
financial data from bigquery to an
external table again
they are blocked vpc service controls
request is prohibited by organizations
policy
vpc service controls going back to the
sec threats page
a new finding under the bigquery data
exfiltration category
has surfaced showing the vpc perimeter
violation
congratulations you've set up bigquery
data exfiltration
using event threat detection for
security command center and learn how to
respond to a finding from it
[Music]
you